brenton johnson en direct de braydon
conti ou une tragédie vient de se
produire un conducteur en état d'ébriété
a fauché la jeune angela east qui venait
de fêter ses 12 ans la victime apprécié
de tous les résidents de braye notts
county laisse derrière elle un périple
au riz
mais elle a fait beaucoup de progrès ici
je suis persuadé qu'elle s'en sortira
pour sortir de la dépression elle a
besoin de passer du temps avec ses amis
n'en tienne arrêt de tout et pour rien
ne vient pas
les filles vous devriez faire demi tour
pendant qu'il est encore temps n'allait
pas dans cette forêt jared est
introuvable tirons-nous un truc qui
déconne vous avez entendu quoi
qui voudrait vivre ici mais je sais pas
mais qu'est ce qu'on a à perdre
maintenant
bah